Venho falar-vos de algo
que não tem merecido a vossa atenção.
Sobre isso, venho dizer
que vocês são, eventualmente,
a última esperança
para mudarmos o atual estado de coisas.
O meu ponto aqui é o bom jornalismo,
ou melhor, o que podemos
fazer para salvá-lo.
Não é muito fácil definir
o que seja isso do bom jornalismo.
Como tudo, facilmente estaremos de acordo
que o mau jornalismo provoca em nós
visões distorcidas
e enviesadas da realidade.
Com o mau jornalismo,
ficamos incapacitados
de formular juízos, perceções da realidade
que sejam bem fundamentados.
O bom jornalismo é aquele que se atreve
a trazer para a praça pública
as questões, as decisões, os dossiês
que os poderes, todos os poderes,
qualquer tipo de poder,
tentam evitar que venham
para a praça pública,
que querem manter escondidos.
É graças ao bom jornalismo
que nós podemos fazer uma ideia
mais perto e mais certa
do que é a realidade.
Mas será que nós podemos
fazer alguma coisa
a favor do bom jornalismo?
Será que, ainda hoje,
no tempo da Internet,
da "web", das redes sociais,
o jornalismo, os "medias" tradicionais
têm algum peso?
Têm alguma importância?
Creio que aqui, nesta sala,
a maior parte de vós, bastante
mais novos do que eu,
tem a ideia de que não.
Que, graças à Internet, às redes sociais,
aos meios, aos vossos
conhecimentos específicos,
podem tomar consciência,
tomar conhecimento,
saber aquilo que realmente vos interessa,
que vos interessa.
Essa é que é a questão.
É que é verdade.
Nós, na Internet, graças
às nossas capacidades de procurarmos,
podemos com facilidade aumentar
a nossa consciência
daquilo que nos interessa.
Contudo, são ainda os "media" tradicionais
que, pela diversidade
de informação que juntam,
pela forma como a hierarquizam,
são eles que constroem para nós
uma perceção da realidade
que é partilhada pela nossa comunidade,
inclusive por aqueles que não frequentam
esses "media" tradicionais.
E então? pergunto-vos.
Um bom jornalismo será
muito, pouco ou nada importante
para a sociedade que estamos a viver hoje
e para o futuro que queremos construir?
Não é suposto, nestas conferências,
vocês responderem,
portanto vocês ficam
com a pergunta para o intervalo.
Eu, por mim, acho que sim.
Acho que sim.
Mas, antes de elaborar um pouco mais
sobre esse assunto,
quero-vos convidar a irem comigo
fazer uma curta viagem
daqui até Madrid,
no princípio dos anos 90.
O La Republica e o El País
tinham acabado de comprar
a parte do capital social
do jornal Público
de cuja direção eu fazia parte.
Lembro-me de ter perguntado
a Juan Luís Cébrian,
o diretor do El País desde o início,
como é que era, como é que se explicava
que o El País, naquelas condições
específicas de Espanha
tivesse feito sempre
um jornalismo exemplar,
de qualidade e independente.
Lembro-me que ele me respondeu:
"Tivemos sorte, tivemos muita sorte.
"É verdade que tivemos, desde o princípio,
"o jornalismo de que Espanha
e os espanhóis precisavam,
"mas tivemos sorte.
"Tivemos sobretudo sorte,
"porque demos dinheiro ao nosso investidor
"desde o primeiro ano.
"Se tu queres ser realmente independente,
"se queres preservar
a tua independência editorial,
"se queres que os teus leitores
tenham confiança em ti,
"tu tens que dar dinheiro,
tens que ganhar dinheiro".
Este, no fundo, foi o modelo
durante muitos anos
que suportou o bom jornalismo.
E era muito simples.
Os leitores pagavam para ler,
os anunciantes pagavam fortunas
pelo espaço de publicidade que compravam.
Com esses recursos,
as redações tinham
disponibilidades financeiras,
tinham capacidade de pessoas,
equipas que eram capazes
de gastar dias, anos
— anos talvez não —
semanas, para investigar um assunto,
para não se contentarem
com a versão oficial dele
para irem mais longe,
para porem na agenda e na praça pública
assuntos que mais ninguém
queria ver na praça pública.
Tenho más notícias.
Esse mundo acabou.
Em Portugal, muito poucas são
as empresas jornalísticas
que dão lucro, que ganham dinheiro.
Portanto, hoje estamos numa situação
em que, fundamentalmente,
por causa de coisas boas e interessantes,
nomeadamente, por causa da Internet,
pela expansão e explosão
das redes sociais,
por esta ideia de que
a informação não se paga
tem que se aceder à informação
sem ser necessário pagar,
por tudo isto e pela explosão
duma quantidade de canais de informação
que existem hoje no mundo,
a publicidade não paga as redações,
os leitores não querem pagar a informação.
Ninguém quer pagar a informação
a que julga que tem direito — e tem.
Nesta situação, o que nos aconteceu
foi que progressivamente as redações
ficaram cada vez mais pequenas
cada vez mais, e permanentemente,
reduzidas a jovens estagiários
pouco conhecedores das situações,
dos factos, das histórias
dos protagonistas,
e com redações tão pequenas,
mesmo com jornalistas
que querem fazer bom jornalismo
é muito fácil abrir as janelas,
escancarar a porta
ao jornalismo sensacionalista
que não perde tempo a investigar os factos
ou a pôr em causa
a versão dos acontecimentos
que lhe é vendida por todo
o tipo e género de porta-vozes.
Estamos, portanto,
numa situação bastante complexa.
Eu diria mesmo que esta crise
de desinvestimento nas redações,
salvo honrosas exceções,
é seguramente um dos problemas graves
das nossas democracias contemporâneas.
E então? Nós?
Que podemos fazer?
Nós, que até não nos interessamos
muito pelos "media" tradicionais,
podemos fazer alguma coisa?
Já vos respondo mas,
primeiro, venham comigo
fazer uma pequena viagem no tempo.
Na segunda metade dos anos 90,
uma só leitora queixou-se
que o Público tinha maltratado
uma informação que punha em causa
a gestão camarária
duma determinada câmara.
Claro, estávamos em pré-campanha
eleitoral para as autárquicas,
e essa leitora era uma parte interessada.
Mas eu que, então,
era Provedor do Leitor do Público,
dei-lhe toda a razão
e zurzi bastante criticamente
o editor que tinha permitido
que tal notícia fosse editada.
Passado algum tempo,
esse editor deixou o jornal.
Numa forma bastante
mais impressionante e mais recente,
Peter Osborne, o comentador político
dum jornal importante, o The Telegraph
deixou o seu cargo.
Em 17 de fevereiro deste ano,
publicou um extenso documento
em que referia as tropelias
que os editores do The Telegraph
tinham vindo a fazer nos últimos meses
para esconder e omitir notícias
que eram prejudiciais
aos seus investidores em geral,
sobretudo aqueles que compravam
a publicidade aos seus anunciantes.
Peter deixou muito claro que, para ele,
era absolutamente insuportável
continuar a viver e a trabalhar num jornal
cujos leitores se queixavam,
dizendo que já não reconheciam
naquele "papel"
o jornal que tinha sido o seu.
Mais recentemente, também,
um estudo conduzido nos EUA
por Arthur Santana
mostrava que 98% (!)
dos jornalistas americanos,
dos jornais diários de âmbito nacional
da costa este e da costa oeste,
98% reconheciam que liam
as críticas que lhes eram feitas.
Um pouco mais de três quartos
dos jornalistas
respondiam a esse inquérito, dizendo que
a sua visão do que era o valor notícia
tinha mudado
pelo facto de lerem
os comentários àquilo que eles publicavam.
Portanto, nós, o público, nós temos força.
Nós temos poder.
Mesmo que as redações digam
que não senhora, que não percebemos
nada do ofício deles
que os seus telespetadores,
ouvintes e espetadores nada entendem
do que é ser jornalista,
não é verdade.
Eles têm em conta,
mudam as suas perspetivas,
mudam as suas prioridades
mudam o seu modo de fazer
a notícia e de a publicar,
mudam a sua agenda,
na medida em que são criticados.
Não se esqueçam.
Os jornalistas pouco mais têm,
além do seu próprio nome.
E verem o seu próprio nome
posto em causa na praça pública,
é algo que dói.
Portanto, a minha mensagem aqui é simples.
Podemos fazer.
Meios: cartas, telefonemas,
protestos contra o mau jornalismo
é, de certeza, um modo de lutarmos
pelo bom jornalismo,
de nos aliarmos aos bons jornalistas
e de puxarmos por eles.
Isso tem impacto, garanto-vos.
Portanto, deem-se ao trabalho
de serem críticos,
de reagirem criticamente
àquilo que é de, alguma forma,
o que leem, veem e ouvem.
Sem dúvida, tudo isto exige tempo.
Escrever cartas
para diretores de informação,
provedores de leitor, etc. exige trabalho.
Mas como o que está em jogo
é muito, muito importante,
eu acho que vale a pena, não acham?
Muito obrigado.
(Aplausos)